[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
yo estoy segura que todos ustedes en
algún momento de su vida en su infancia
jugaron con panaderos los soplaron
pidieron un deseo algo parecido a lo que
yo acabo de hacer
pero de lo que no estoy tan segura es de
si alguno de ustedes se habrá animado a
hacer esto
taraxacum oficina leo diente de león
como me imagino que conocerán a esta
planta es una maleza un suyo una planta
común y corriente que todos conocemos o
la mayoría conocemos es una planta
cosmopolita que se adapta a muchos
diferentes ambientes alrededor del mundo
que crece con fuerza
pero hoy yo les vengo a contar que
además de todo eso esta planta también
es un alimento
y no les hablo de cualquier alimento
sino de un superalimento tiene en sus
hojas más hierro que la espinaca y más
calcio que la leche y además es
aprovechable en su integridad
las hojas como les acabo de mostrar se
pueden comer frescas o cocidas las
flores sirven para preparar infusiones
pero también pueden hacerse en conserva
o servir para preparar dulces y con la
raíz es posible tostando y moliendo la
hacer una infusión muy similar al café
sin embargo me imagino que para la gran
mayoría de la audiencia hasta hace
apenas unos minutos esto no era más que
un suyo una planta que sacamos de
nuestro pasto para que no nos [ __ ] o
sacamos del cantero para que no estropee
nuestras flores
yo les vengo a contar otra cosa de esta
planta y les vengo a contar la manera en
la que no fue arbitraria yo comencé a
probar y comer algunas malezas
mi historia es sencilla yo soy bióloga
como ya escucharon la presentación y ya
desde los últimos años de mi carrera me
dediqué a la autoproducción de alimentos
siempre enmarcada en la agroecología es
decir buscando la manera en la que esa
producción fuera ecológicamente
sustentable
estudié mucho sobre una dualidad que
para los que trabajamos en la
autoproducción de alimentos es bastante
común y en un campo existen malezas y
existen cultivos de interés
fue en ese rumbo que entonces me adentré
en el mundo de las malezas para aprender
a controlarlas a combatirlas a que no
perjudicarán de alguna manera mi fin o
último que era maximizar la producción
de alimentos en detrimento de este otro
grupo de plantas que debía aprender a
reconocer estudie sus fortalezas sus
debilidades la manera en la que
compartían
en fin
una historia como la de puede ser muchas
otras personas sin embargo hubo un día
en el que yo me replanteé seriamente que
estaba entendiendo por alimento y eso
también lleva a otra historia breve
la verdad es que me gusta mucho comer y
me gusta viajar y me gusta que entonces
mis viajes se conviertan en experiencias
gastronómicas me gusta probar cosas
nuevas
incorporar esas nuevas cosas en el caso
de que pueda a mis recetas cotidianas
traerlas a mi casa y fue así que en un
viaje en méxico en un pueblito muy
chiquitito un mediodía una señora me
sirvió un potaje un guiso que me resultó
realmente muy rico pero desconocido
cuando le pregunté de qué estaba hecho
esta señora me dijo que estaba hecho de
verdolaga
yo conocía muy bien la verdolaga sin
embargo como estaba en otro país me
imaginé que esa verdolaga no debía ser
la misma verdolaga con la que yo tanto
había renegado
un clic en google y descubrí que si
efectivamente se trataba de la misma
y esa manera algo en mí explotó
esta dualidad sobre la cual se había
trabajado cultivo o maleza
había desaparecido y una planta había
dejado de ser una maleza para
convertirse en un alimento porque para
esa señora les aseguro que esa planta de
ninguna manera era una maleza
existen muchas definiciones para saber
qué es una maleza por lo general
pensamos que es una planta que crece
sola
y en este montón de definiciones yo les
aseguro que todas estas son siempre
antropocéntricas es decir hablan de lo
útil o inútil que esta planta resulta
para el hombre
una maleza es una planta que crece en un
lugar indebido
y yo podría entonces decirle que una
planta de trigo creciendo en un campo de
girasoles sería una maleza y no me
apartaría de la definición
una maleza entonces es una planta que no
sirve no sirve en ese momento me gusta
pensar en la etimología en el sonido de
la palabra maleza claramente es algo que
vino a hacernos mal y esto no sólo
ocurre en español sino que por ejemplo
en portugués es una sba dañina en
italiano es un arva che siempre hay algo
de peso nativo despectivo la manera en
la que nos referimos
todas estas reflexiones seriamente me
hicieron repensar sobre él porque en
algún momento de la historia algunas
plantas han sido beneficiadas
favorecidas y consideradas alimento y
entonces si las conocemos las cuidamos
las sembramos las regamos las compramos
y las vendemos
sin embargo hay otro grupo enorme que
caen en la aventura de ser consideradas
malezas y entonces no las controlamos
las erradicamos las pisamos no sabemos
siquiera su nombre y esta forma se
vuelven de alguna manera invisible en
nuestro paisaje cotidiano
miren la verdad es que con solo un poco
de interés en el tema no puede
investigar y descubrir que son
muchísimas pero muchísimas las malezas
que pueden ser alimentos que son
comestibles sin embargo esta no es
información que se divulga
y ese es el rumbo que tomo mi carrera
porque además les estoy hablando de
plantas que en muchos casos son
consumidas con otros fines medicinales
como sucede con el diente de león
pero no alimenticios y en otros casos
son parientes cercanos de las plantas
que si comemos consumimos y compramos
que sin embargo por algún motivo
arbitrario han quedado de lado esos
motivos muchas veces son menores como
que un tallo es más peludo que el otro
una hoja más fácil de lavar que otra
y así fuimos generando esta dualidad
esa dualidad además se vio representada
con la llegada de la tecnología agrícola
y el reemplazo de la mano del hombre por
la maquinaria el uso y el abuso de los
agroquímicos
el monocultivo como la forma reinante de
producción
todo este pack tecnológico lo que hace
es alejarnos un poder fundamental
elegir que vamos a comer
esto nos aleja como pueblo de un
concepto importante que debemos entender
que es el de la soberanía alimentaria
porque aparte yo les quiero decir
que esto empobrece nuestras dietas
empobrece la calidad nutricional los
invito a visitar la verdulería que se
les antoje incluso la más surtida que
puedan pensar yo les aseguro que no es
mucha la variedad de cosas que nos
ofrecen algunas hojas tubérculos raíces
no hay mucho más frutas algunas traídas
de algún lugar más cerca y otras más
lejanos
pero nunca una flor muy pocas semillas
porque además yo les aseguro que resulta
hasta divertido anecdótico que una
actividad en familia sea un paseo que
pueda convertirse en una recolección
y que esa recolección se convierta en
unas empanadas
o que incluso una maceta de mi balcón
puede hacer una ensalada
y voy más lejos para los que tienen
huertas para los que están en el camino
de la producción de sus alimentos
tal vez empiecen a darse cuenta que
tienen muchos más alimentos de los que
pensaban y dejen de arrancar la ortiga y
empiecen a ver de qué manera la pueden
cocinar
porque al margen de todo esto yo les
quiero contar que no les estoy hablando
de plantas que son exóticas y que sólo
serían reconocibles ante los ojos de un
experto
yo les estoy hablando del diente de león
les estoy hablando de la verdolaga
les estoy hablando de la ortiga en sant
en el vinagre
la flor de la pasión o el taco de reina
plantas que forman parte de nuestro
paisaje cotidiano y que son abundantes y
que estarían ahí disponibles para ser
tomadas
sin embargo muchas veces por nuestra
forma de vivir caótica citadina
acelerada vamos tomando costumbres
que nos alejan de la posibilidad de
elegir verdaderamente qué vamos a comer
y que con reeducar un poco nuestro
paladar y reaprender cosas que
sinceramente nuestros abuelos ya sabían
como por ejemplo que cuando una planta
es comestible por lo general toda la
planta es comestible lo llevó de vuelta
a la verdulería y a pensar en cuando
compramos remolachas por ejemplo es muy
común que nuestro verdulero o verdulera
amiga nos ofrezca cortarnos las hojas
para que no haga bulto en nuestra bolsa
sin embargo estas hojas que desechamos
no tienen no difieren ni en sabor ni en
cualidades nutricionales de las hojas de
la acelga que son hojas que si compramos
a este tipo de cosas también me refiero
porque ese poder que nosotros perdemos
se lo dejamos en manos a los dueños de
la tierra que no hablo por supuesto ni
de huerteros ni de quinteros ni de
agricultores pequeños y familiares hablo
de los terratenientes de argentina los
dueños de mucha tierra
que hoy deciden que argentina sea un
país sojero
y lo decían simplemente porque es el
cultivo que más rinde tiene
mi pregunta es sincera
y yo quisiera saber quién verdaderamente
elige comer soja
yo no
- esa soja transgénica esa soja bañada
de agrotóxicos esa soja que contamina
tanto la tierra como el agua como el
aire esa soja que enferma y mata a la
persona que trabaja la tierra que
enferma y mata a su familia que convive
en el territorio
porque yo hoy les aseguro que acá somos
un grupo de privilegiados que nos
reunimos en torno a un evento importante
y estamos todos acá muy lindos bien
vestidos les aseguro que no hay nadie en
esta sala que no tenga el l fosfato en
su sangre
yo no les vengo a decir que las malezas
comestibles son la solución a este
problema que es un problema ambiental y
que como tal debe ser abordado sin duda
desde la política no estoy loca para
pensar eso pero si lo que les quiero
decir es que es una ventana una
posibilidad es una molestia en el
sistema no quiero dejar de recalcar que
es alimento gratis en un mundo que pasa
hambre que es alimento que está
disponible para quien guste tomarlo para
quien sepa reconocerlo y guste tomarlo
porque si hay algo que aprendí de las
malezas cuando trataba de controlarlas
es que tienen mucha fuerza y que se
reproducen muy fácilmente pese a todos
los esfuerzos que hagamos
ahí están a veces basta un poquito de
tierra entre dos baldosas para que
aparezcan imagínense si esa fuerza
encima la ayudamos un poco le damos algo
de tierra mejor
le damos el permiso a cristal
yo empecé mi charla su plan panadero y
pidiendo tres deseos
y lejos de creer que me pueden traer
mala suerte no contarlo lo quiero
compartir con ustedes
el primero de mis deseos tiene que ver
con que espero al menos haberlos hecho
repensar un poco en su alimentación
y por lo menos en nuestro rol de
consumidores en que empecemos a elegir
qué es lo que comemos y que en algún
futuro podamos como pueblo sinceramente
decidir nuestra soberanía para
asegurarnos seguridad en nuestra
alimentación y en la de nuestras
generaciones futuras
el segundo de mis deseos y tiene que ver
con las malezas comestibles y adentro de
sus bolsitas hay una receta que espero
que se animen a probar y a los que no se
animen a tanto espero por lo menos que
les haya sacado el mote despectivo a
este grupo de plantas y las empiecen a
mirar con otros ojos
el último de mis deseos es más grande
yo les conté que viví mucho tiempo en
una dualidad en una estructura asumida
que era que algo es un cultivo o es una
maleza
pero un día algo se rompió y yo sentí
que esa información era información que
la tenía que dar a conocer y en ese
camino estoy yo estoy segura que todos
vivimos rompiendo estructuras y que
debemos animarnos a que eso suceda
porque esa es una manera de transformar
las realidades para hacer un mundo que
sea más justo y que en definitiva no va
a ser ni más ni menos que un mundo mejor
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]